- [Instructor] We are asked to estimate
what is 2.7 times 4 roughly equal to?
Pause this video and see
if you can answer that.
Alright, so we can think of 2.7 times 4
as being roughly equal to,
or some people might say,
as approximately equal to.
Well let's see, 2.7, that's two ones
and seven tenths.
So we could think about
well what's the nearest
whole number to 2.7?
And so 2.7 is pretty close to 3,
it's in fact closer to 3 than it is to 2.
So we could say that this is roughly
equal to three times four.
And then three times four is, of course,
equal to 12.
And you can see that these other answers
actually seem quite unreasonable.
1.2, if I take something
and I multiply times four,
I shouldn't get an answer that is
less than my original something.
And then to go from,
and then to take something that's
roughly equal to three times four
to get to 120, that doesn't make sense,
and definitely doesn't
make sense to get to 1,200.
Let's do another example.
So here we said what is roughly
equal to 78 times 19.88.
So pause this video
and try to answer that.
Alright, well this is
really the same idea.
We wanna think about,
well what are numbers that
these numbers are close to
that are easy to multiply with.
So for example, 78, that
is pretty close to 80
and then 19.88, or 19 and 88 hundredths,
that's pretty close to 20.
It's closer to 20 than it is to 19
and even if it was closer to 19,
just to estimate I probably
would still go to 20
because it's easier to multiply with 20.
So this is going to be pretty close to 20.
So all of this is going to be roughly
equal to 80 times 20.
And you might already recognize
that this is going to be 8
times 2 times 10 times 10
and I could write it that way,
no reason for me to skip steps.
But you would normally
do this in your head.
So 80 is the same thing as 8 times 10,
we do that in that purple color
so that you can see it.
So this is the same thing as 8 times 10
times two times ten
which we could then write
this is going to be 8 times 2 which is 16,
so the 8 and the 2, you
get 16 times 10 times 10
is times 100 so this should be 1,600.
1,600 which is this
choice right over here.
And it's always good to
just do reality check
to make sure it's reasonable.
It wouldn't make any sense if I
take a number close to 80
and I multiply it by some
number that's close to 20
and get a smaller number than 80.
It also, if you have a
number that's close to 80,
to get 160 you'd only have to multiply
it by roughly 2.
But here we're multiplying by roughly 20.
And then to go to 80, or
roughly 80, to 16,000,
well then you wouldn't have to multiply
by something that's close to 20,
you'd have to multiply by something
that's close to 200.
So I like our answer.